this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in
a bit visitors to the Saratoga National
Historic Park New York may see the bhoot
Monument a frieze that commemorates the
Battle of Saratoga one of the most
significant wins for the Americans over
the British during the Revolutionary War
specifically it honors one officer
described as the most brilliant soldier
of the Continental Army and although it
is extremely bizarre it does not show
his likeness or even name the officer in
question there is a reason for that the
monument is dedicated to Benedict Arnold
a man presented in history classes
around the United States as the most
notorious traitor in the country's
history there is no better
exemplification of the conundrum posed
by Arnold than the bhoot monument before
he betrayed his country he had several
victories they were instrumental to the
overall success of the Continental Army
however constant arguments with his
peers and being the target of numerous
slights and insults both real and
perceived eventually persuaded him to
switch sides and attempt to surrender
West Point to the British that's how we
ended up with strange things like a
memorial that does not name its honoree
people wanted to praise Arnold's early
career but at the same time the mere
mention of his name revolts many
Americans know in case you were
wondering the monument was not erected
before
Arnold's betrayal in fact it was built
over a hundred years later at the behest
of John watts to paste-up himself a
Major General during the Civil War
there's a certain Jekyll & Hyde
element Arnold's legacy and today we're
going to try to unravel as best we can
the tale of the unnamed hero and the
despicable villain that was Benedict
Arnold
Benedict Arnold was born on January the
14th 1741 in Norwich then a part of the
colony of Connecticut the second of six
children his parents were Benedict
Arnold senior and Hannah a Waterman King
in fact the younger Arnold was the
fourth Benedict in his family all named
after his great grandfather who served
as the governor of the colony of Rhode
Island and Providence Plantations on his
mother's side Arnold was descended from
Reverend John Lothrop sometimes a
thorough and influential New England
clergyman who helped settle the city of
Barnstable Massachusetts and was one of
the first people in the colonies to
champion the idea of separation of
church and state at first it seems like
Arnold's would have an easy ride through
life he was born into a wealthy family
and his father was a successful
businessman he went to private school in
Canterbury Connecticut and was expected
to continue his studies at a prestigious
university most likely Yale however when
he was a teenager three of his siblings
died of yellow fever his father did not
take their loss as well and started
drinking heavily in turn this led to
multiple failed business deals until
eventually he lost the family company
with the money gone the Arnold said no
choice but to pull young Benedict's from
school and find him work his mother
appeals to two other cousins Daniel and
Joshua Lathrop to take him on as their
apprentice to their expanding apothecary
business so that he could learn at rate
she died a few years later in 1759
followed by her husband two years after
that
Arnold proved to be an adept merchant
once his apprenticeship was finished he
borrowed money from his uncles and
travelled to Europe to secure goods he
opened his own apothecary in New Haven
which proved to be successful in just a
few years he managed to settle all of
his family's debts he also married
Margaret Mansfield in 1767 and they had
three children together
before her death in 1775
[Music]
ahnold's military career kicked off
almost two decades before the
Revolutionary War as a youth he wanted
to fight in the French and Indian War
against his mother's wishes
eventually he managed to join a
Connecticut militia but as far as we can
tell he never actually saw combat as a
successful businessman Arnold felt the
oppressive boot of the British
government more and more the sugar and
stamp acts were passed in 1764 in 1765
respectively to tax the North American
colonies this was an attempts to
increase revenue by a government that
was hurting financially following the
Seven Years War but unsurprisingly it
proved to be wildly unpopular in North
America response to the new taxes was
almost universally negative but to
varying degrees some tried to take the
legal reasons argued that it was
unconstitutional for the government to
levy direct taxes since only their
representative assemblies could do this
no taxation without representation
became their rallying slogan others
resorted to mob violence to deter debt
collectors from doing their jobs
meanwhile Benedict Arnold's and many
blackened simply continued to operate
normally in defiance of the British
government which technically turns him
into a smuggler he also joins the Sons
of Liberty a secret organization that
sought to protect the interests of
colonists against the British crown
Arnold's first position during the
Revolutionary War was as a captain with
the New Haven militia called the second
company of Governors foot guard when the
battles at Lexington and Concord
signaled the start of the conflict his
men were ready to march well hold on a
minute
not so fast the militia was ready to go
but the New Haven Town Council led by
David Worcester had a meeting and
decided that they should wait for
regular orders consequently they refused
to release any gunpowder to these
soldiers back then because gunpowder was
so volatile and dangerous a town's
entire supply was generally kept in one
safe place usually a magazine or a
church basements and the keys were
carefully safeguarded frustrated by the
denial
Arnold confronted we stir in a tavern
and demanded the keys saying that he
intended to march free even if he had to
break into the powder house the Town
Council relented and after arming
themselves the militia troops to
Cambridge Massachusetts this little
moment of glory for Benedict Arnold is
well remembered in New Haven since 1904
the city commemorates it every year on
April the 22nd as powder house day
Arnold's militia was on its way to take
part in the siege of Boston butts on the
way met Colonel Samuel Holton Parsons
the two of them discussed the
Continental Army's desperate need for
artillery and brought up the fact that
for Ticonderoga had plenty of cannons
guarded only by a small force they
agreed that the fort would be a great
asset to them so while Parsons continued
his journey
Arnold went to Cambridge where he
persuaded the Massachusetts Committee of
Safety to fund his expedition to capture
the fort now we arrived at the first
instance where Arnold felt slighted by
his own sight he was not the only one
planning to attack Fort Ticonderoga a
second militia from the New Hampshire
grants school to the Green Mountain Boys
were also enroute they were led by Ethan
Allen a man who would go on to become
one of the founders of Vermont Arnold on
Allen did not get along and this was the
first in a series of rivalries that
Benedict would have with his fellow
officers whether or not he was justified
in his enmity we cannot really say with
certainty since both sides gave their
own
versions of the story Benedict Arnold
had been made a colonel and had official
orders to lead the charge on Fort
Ticonderoga this did not mean anything
to Alan who refused to relinquish
commands nor to his Green Mountain Boys
who would not obey the orders of any
other officer they knew they had all the
leverage because they accounted for the
bulk of the military force eventually
Arnold had no choice but to concede and
accept Ethan Allen as the co-leader of
the expedition some historians see it as
even more insulting to Arnold they
argued that he was only allowed to ride
at the front of the military column
alongside Allen for pure symbolism and
had no actual authority we should
mention that there was also a third
smaller force that was led by one
Colonel James Easton who got along even
worse with Arnold's and their
relationship eventually descended into
violence according to Arnold's journal
he took the liberty of breaking his head
and then challenging Easton to a duel
when the latter refused to relinquish
his other weapons and draw like a
gentleman Arnold kicked him very
heartily and told him to leave the point
and look you might not be keeping a
journal where you describe the duels
you're challenging people to but if you
run a business or have an online
presence a modern journal a blog might
be right up your street and that
transition brings me to today's sponsor
who makes this video possible
Squarespace 2 simple things 1 maybe
you've got some idea for a website or a
business or a YouTube channel or a
podcast or something like that knocking
the rounds up there in your brain and
well number two is the only way to
figure out whether it's worth doing is
to get it out to the world and see if
they like it yes that can be daunting
because it's scary to pursue new things
but not knowing how the set of a website
is not an excuse there are no excuses
available when you use Squarespace
Squarespace allow you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to you want to sell something online yes
set up a store with Squarespace starting
a youtube channel while you want a
website to complement that it all starts
on Squarespace with a beautiful template
that you can customize to your heart's
content or you can start from scratch or
just easily move over from an existing
domain making everything very easy to
manage my recommendation don't start
from scratch use a template just get
started knowing
users and once you've gone through the
super easy customization process there's
no update so there's no patches there's
no tech BS to deal with and Squarespace
also handle all our website e stuff like
I said they do podcasts they also do
mailing lists social media integrations
it's all there like I say Squarespace
remove the excuses to your dreams so
just do it
also there's 24/7 customer support if
you have any hiccups on the way to your
dreams they're there to help you out
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm forward slash buyer
graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain and
let's get back to Benedict Arnold
despite the animosity between Arnold and
his fellow officers the attack on Fort
Ticonderoga was an unmitigated success
during the early hours of May the 10th
1775 around 80 soldiers crossed Lake
Champlain undetected and snuck into the
fort taking the British garrison by
surprise
the militia managed to capture the
Citadel without any fatalities from
there the men also took the nearby Fort
George and fought crown points which and
even fewer soldiers guarding them this
victory was cause for celebration
according to Arnold's Journal the Green
Mountain Boys brokens the rum supply and
drank themselves into a stupor meanwhile
his own captain started to show up with
additional men now he had a sizable
force to his side Arnold
sought to claim some glory for himself
his target was false and on the Canadian
side of Lake Champlain like the other
fortresses it was poorly guarded but it
also had the HMS Royal Gorge the only
major warship in those waters it would
have been a fitting prize for the
ambitious officer who knew that Ethan
Allen would try to claim as much credit
as possible for the capture of Fort
Ticonderoga indeed when he wrote his
memoir Allen neglected to mention
Benedict Arnold by name a week after
taking Ticonderoga Arnold's men rode in
small boats and reached forts and Jean
undetected the element of surprise was
enough to overpower the small garrison
but Arnold found out that a large
British force was on its way from
Montreal the capture of the fort turned
into a raid Arnold and his men took all
the supplies they could aboard the
Royal Gorge and sunk everything else
Arnold decided to rechristened the
warship the USS Enterprise it became the
first in a long line of prestigious
American ships that carried that name a
tradition which if Star Trek is to be
believed will continue hundreds of years
into the future
Ethan Allen and his men they started to
disperse from Fort Ticonderoga and
Arnold assumes that he would take
command instead Colonel Benjamin Hinman
arrived with a large force of a thousand
soldiers and orders from Connecticut
Governor Jonathan Trumbull which said
that Arnold would serve as his
subordinate incensed by another
perceived injustice all over resigned
his commission and headed home on the
way he learns that his wife passed away
and shortly after Arnold himself was
struck by Ghouta
painful disease which would plague him
for the rest of his life despite these
setbacks Arnold was not quite ready to
give up on the military life just yet
among others he was of the opinion that
the Continental Army's next move should
be to invade Quebec via their newly
gained foothold on Lake Champlain this
would deny the British a solid base of
operations should they want to charge
into New York again Arnold was refused
the opportunity to lead the expedition
with that on are going to Major General
Philip Shula it sounds out to be quite a
rarity as he was a continental officer
the Benedict Arnold actually got along
with however he was stricken by illness
and was forced to relinquish command to
Brigadier General Richard Montgomery
Arnold convinced his superiors that a
two-pronged attack would work better he
was given 1,100 men and two Colonels
commissioned by George Washington
himself and told to meet up with
Montgomery's forces and take Quebec City
there was just one problem in order for
the assault to work Arnold had to take
his troops through the harsh wilderness
of Maine and Quebec over rough terrain
in cold September weather almost half of
his soldiers died or deserted before
they reached their goal meanwhile the
British got wind of this plant attack
and shot up their defenses the 600 or so
soldiers he remains joins up with an
equal force commanded by General
Montgomery and on December 31st 1775
they attacked Quebec City the battle was
a disaster for the Continental forces
Montgomery died leading the assault most
of his soldiers were killed injured or
taken prisoner there remain
forces fell under the command of
Benedict Arnold who sustained a leg
injury during the fight instead of
retreating Arnold decided to maintain a
siege on the city in the hopes that
reinforcements would come new units did
arrive commanded by David Worcester the
same man who didn't want to supply
Arnold's militia with gunpowder
he was now a Major General and took
control of the siege while Arnold
travelled to Montreal as a consolation
prize he found out that he had been
promoted to Brigadier General for his
efforts Continental forces gave up on
Quebec City once British reinforcements
were on the way and it became clear that
there was no salvaging that disastrous
mission unsurprisingly the enemy pressed
their advantage and continued on to
Montreal to gain back the territory that
they had lost in Canada
Arnold spent the rest of the year in
Quebec trying to slow down the advance
of the British as much as possible he
distinguished himself in two conflicts
the Battle of the Cedars and the Battle
of Valcour Island however because it had
been awhile since he had Ed on arguments
with another officer Arnold brought
charges of dereliction of duty against
general Moses Hazen he claims that the
Lasser had refused to take goods from
Montreal merchants and send them to
supply Arnold's garrison this led to a
court-martial for Hazen but his rank his
service and disconnections
ensured that he got off in turn he
pressed counter charges against Arnold
and had him court-martialed moreover he
was joined by two junior officers who
had their own issues with Arnold John
Brown and the aforementioned James
Easton unlike Hazen auld was never
honorably acquitted of the accusations
against him instead general Horatio
Gates intervened and dissolved the
arrest warrants believing that the
Brigadier General was too valuable in
battle to lose every legal matters it
certainly sounds like Gates was on the
same page as Arnold's but stick around
because that wasn't going to last very
long meanwhile in a rather prophetic
move John Brown was not content with
ruling in Arnold's favor he wanted the
world to know what kind of man the
general was and distributed a pamphlet
where he wrote of Benedict Arnold's that
money is this man's God and to get
enough of it he would sacrifice his
country
[Music]
we are now approaching the crowning
achievements of Benedict Arnold's
military career his service during the
battles of Saratoga however it almost
never happens because once again he
wanted to resign his position on all the
words angered by the fact that several
junior officers some of them his enemies
were promoted to Major General ahead of
him it was only due to George
Washington's direct interference that he
decided to postpone his resignation and
instead serve under general Shula at
Saratoga eventually the Continental
Congress promoted on all to Major
General but refused to reinstate his
seniority meaning that those junior
officers still remained his superiors at
Saratoga Arnold found out not only of
Congress's refusal to restore his
seniority but also that Schiller had
been replaced with general Horatio Gates
the general might have defended Arnold
during his corps marshal but their
relationship soured quickly on the
battlefield as they had opposing views
on how to approach the military campaign
the first engagements occurred on
September 19th against British forces
led by General John Burgoyne dubs the
Battle of Freeman's farm there was a
Pyrrhic victory for the British they
might have won the fields but they
suffered greater casualties and failed
to weaken the American position most of
the success was due to Arnold who wanted
to be aggressive and took his regiments
to meet the British head-on however he
felt that he didn't receive proper
credit in the reports that were written
by Gates's party and he began butting
heads with his superior officer one
shouting match got so heated that gates
relieved Arnold of his commands although
for an unclear reason the latter
remained in camp this proved
instrumental in the second clash
Saratoga known as the Battle of Venice
Heights according to the controversial
story Arnold ignored Gates's orders and
charged into battle at a critical point
rallied the men and captured a British
redoubt it was also at this point that
Arnold was shot in the leg and then had
it crushed by his horse when it fell on
it a newly discovered letter suggests
that Arnold had a superiors permission
to engage but this is besides the point
what matters is that Benedict Arnold
ensured a victory for the Continental
Army and it played a pivotal role in the
outcome of the Revolutionary War a few
days later General Burgoyne surrendered
and this was the move that convinced
France to enter the war as an
I against the British following the
battles of Saratoga Arnold's time off
active duty to Heelys injuries in June
1778 after the British withdrew from
Philadelphia Washington placed him in
command of the city his new position
provided Arnold ample opportunity to
enrich himself through various shady
business deals and questionable schemes
the increase in status allowed the Major
General to meet the ship ins one of the
wealthiest most influential families in
Philadelphia he fell in love with
eighteen-year-old Peggy Shippen and the
two married in April of 1779 now it's
important to remember that at this point
in time there were still people in the
colonies who sympathized with the
British governments the ship ins they
were among them now it's impossible to
say with certainty how influential Peggy
was in getting her husband to switch
sides that she definitely exposed him to
a new circle of individuals who shatter
views crucially among them was British
spy chief Major John Andre in fact
historians believe that the two of them
had a romantic tryst before Peggy
married Arnold around the same time the
general had been court-martialed for
abusing his power in Philadelphia he was
found guilty on two charges of using
government transport for personal use
and issuing a pass for a ship that he
had a financial stake in Arnold received
a public chastising from George
Washington he wrote that his sense of
duty compelled him to decry the generals
actions as imprudent and improper
whether this was the straw that broke
the camel's back or he had already made
up his mind at this point we don't know
but Arnold's he decided to betray his
country
[Music]
major Andre acted as a middleman between
Benedict Arnold and Henry Crimson the
British commander in chief in North
America
the offer was 20,000 pounds and a
generals Commission in return Arnold
would surrender West Point a military
post on the Hudson River with
significant strategic value on August
the 3rd 1780 Arnold assumed command and
began weakening the posts defenses by
delaying repairs draining supplies and
reassigning troops communication was
slow and dangerous between him and the
British so it wasn't until late
September that he met Andre again the
plot was exposed on September the 23rd
when the spy was caught by militiamen
who found incriminating papers on him
that detailed their entire plan Andre
was taken into custody but Arnold found
out of his arrest in time to flee to the
British control to New York City aboard
the HMS vulture
Peggy managed to join him and the family
moved to London following the end of the
war major Andre he was hanged as a spy
[Music]
in early October Arnold published an
open letter titled
to the inhabitants of America to explain
why he did it
unsurprisingly it wasn't because of his
constant fights with other officers or
his illicit dealings or his wife's
persuasions it was because of the
tyranny and corruption of Congress and
the leaders of the Continental Army
Arnold argued that once the British
government sorted out the grievances of
Americans there was no reason why the
colonies should not return to the
British Empire he also objected to
America's alliance with Catholic France
as you might expect public reception to
the letter was let's just say
unfavorable to say the least even though
the treasonous plot failed Arnold was
still rewarded handsomely by the British
crown he was granted pay and Pensions
for the whole of his family and a
commission as a brigadier general
however the never distinguished himself
in battle for the remainder of the war
Arnold's life after his betrayal was
fittingly
bereft of any triumph he made several
bad business deals and had to deal with
multiple lawsuits his propensity to
anger his peers continued on the other
side of the pond and in 1792 on or
fought a bloodless duel with James
Maitland the Earl of Lauderdale his gout
have gotten worse and it was affecting
his good leg
eventually he died in a state of
delirium in 1801 aged 60
leaving behind an indebted estate in the
centuries that followed
Benedict Arnold became synonymous with
traitor in the United States with very
few people remembering or caring for
that matter about his service in the war
prior to his betrayal
the only people still troubled by Arnold
are historians who still struggle to
this day to find the most accurate
perspective to look at one of the
country's most controversial figures
from so I really hope you enjoyed the
video please do smash that like button
below and also hit that subscribe button
and when you're doing that hit the bell
and if you already subscribed to go down
and hit the bell anyway so you actually
find out when we put out a new video
that's the way YouTube works it would be
grand if you did that also why not check
out my other channel called highlight
history I'm gonna link to that below and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]